former Trump campaign chairman Paul
Manafort faces new legal trouble this
morning because Special Counsel Robert
Muller claims mana fort violated his
plea bargain prosecutors a legend of
court filing that he lied to the FBI and
the special counsels office on a variety
of subject matters they say Paula Reed
is at the US District Court House in
Washington with more on this story so
Paula help us understand Manta Ford made
a deal back in September to cooperate on
any and all matters related to molars
Russia investigations what they said at
the time so does this finally mean that
that agreement is no longer in put in
place pretty much yes because he agreed
to cooperate with the government in
exchange for many of the charges against
him being dropped but as part of this
agreement he had to provide accurate
information he had to be honest he had
to be truthful about any matters that
the government was interested in
including Russian interference in the
2016 election now that he has allegedly
lied the government is no longer bound
by any of the promises that it made to
him and could potentially refile those
charges it had dropped no mana Ford's
lawyer denies these allegations he says
his client has been truthful have you
heard anything about exactly what he's
accused of lying about well we know that
he has met with Special Counsel several
times but we do not know exactly what it
is that he lied about but gay men afford
is almost 7 years old he's now looking
at likely spending the rest of his life
in prison he was convicted on financial
fraud charges over the summer and now he
has these additional charges in
Washington it all adds up to the
possibility of decades in prison the one
thing that could possibly spare him this
fate is a presidential pardon something
president Trump has signaled that he may
be open to but even a presidential
pardon wouldn't protect him from any
state-level charges bianna Paula thank
you